the Rockets they're locked and loaded
but through the Warriors they have
firepower as well yeah but maybe the war
is avoidable who knows it's the first
time in the Carrera that they're opening
on the road but I wouldn't take too much
in that because they have the second
most consecutive road wins in in the pH
playoff series I will say this they have
the spec you can be cleared to rent that
is average 29 that's fourth long-term in
NBA history now the starting lineups the
boldest presence leading the NBA in the
playoffs in blocked shots
step back my capella post the coast here
is draymond Green with a nice left
here's the N 1 year offensive rebound
cappella flying a require for waffles
but don't down the on their being on the
island check-in the guard like Chris
Paul but here this is just a chance real
unless you can grow during that play
[Music]
by with his the N 1 versus Gerald Green
just bases the month alone here's the
reverse and tough shot by curry
but on the next possession one fast
break point for Houston but here no man
is a higher so make sure you call out
help and give that man some he'll iron
plate ball and how about capela can we
give a big mess of credit biz
[Music]
[Applause]
which active hands comes up with this
deal finds a good job of fighting this
freakin Andre with the finish catch and
shoot Gerald Green
staring down hardin sorry does the right
thing stain on that left hand forcing
them to his right but it's the step back
and here it is ker you have the swish
out for capella nonetheless permit lady
says to James Harden
you remember my work in OKC don't shoot
and all those practices will cross over
capela tries at Hummel shooters in the
league does not settle he gives you a
little heads up and undertakes the
contactor on the defense attacking
Thompson ear and capela does the right
job three white jerseys around them
nice finish at the rim look at that I'm
a fake it to you and then waiting to
come back to me hitting on man wide open
in the corner the handles Chris Paul
the court now he's got the taller a
capella on him he takes them all the way
to the rim with the finish both of these
guys is seven footers and doing it in a
variety of ways it's time for running
hook and the foul
I'm going into the body of learning
right here that takes away the stop
block right there
now the rest all comes from muscle
memory Chris Paul just willed itself we
all know this story first Western campus
champions Lexie they may be candidate
this is one of the place where you go in
her we look at that switch
miscommunication by God
yes how about the hesitation dribble
here by Gordon to get past Kevin Durant
and then switches hand almost loses the
basketball purse or this is what lets
you know if he's a hundred percent
healthy can he attack the beat can he
get inside Houston wants threes and
layups their ability to drive by their
guards with shooters in the corner
pocket game
timeout Rockets tell you what this is
change that Dominique Williams Wilkins
and then in transition coast-to-coast
splits to the predicate counts Paul on
the foul and Cully
to the line in the first half warriors
shot 43 good tip capela had to go
eruption one the 21-point lead is down
to 13 paint layups and then finally some
faith to launch a dagger here from DS
curry rolling
21 points shooting 50% we saw that
reaction in the fourth wave
it's the shoe me mr. shaken right here
taking baked all the way
one hand and let people know this is our
building to shake it right here shake
and bake
[Music]
maybe he was hit in the face by
Livingston on a sec rich Pahl's
collects his third foul and green will
go to the line like how green Kevin in
his left hand all the way to the cup the
two Amir in the floor what a move by
Jordan Livingston the foul how about a
hurry stays with it takes the contact
again if you want to know him Korea's
healthy is not about his jump shot
it's about him penetrating Keith and
this was Mel and this is what you need
no a key on the floor right here on $22
fouled by harden for harden his first to
be fair we talk about all the isolation
a loony called on the foul talk about
not settling for the three which he's
been doing in this series
[Music]
[Applause]
anything else you want to say the
defense the will and what makes him such
a great offensive player that he can
pass and get assists and others involved
as he did on that play and when he adds
deepest to his game so number three on a
bass thereby cp3 under two warriors arms
to find capela then we have two posters
tonight I tell you what we got ourselves
a basketball game and professional score
the potential and one we finally got a
game here in the conference final people
about Golden State look at this screen
right here going to get his ride over to
Golden State average you get him back to
us and talk about pushing hard and right
well he can still finish with this left
going right he needs help defense inside
to help stop that hard to commit up the
foul
[Applause]
the movie about the beautiful moves here
by James Harden this is how you make
their presence
I mean
the city's here's my partner Oh Oh
[Applause]
not blocker Loney is on the best
penetrator you have known heck in the
playoffs the power life from Game four
when Thompson goes off one leg and tries
to go up and under and compel a block
Golden State's finally moving the ball
access denied and this falls only get to
the body of Steph Curry the reverse by
curry the English the most spinny as on
the basket aback 24-second clock
violations for each seized here Durant
coming over with the help again we've
seen Paul make some tough shots they're
going once again proving he is a huge
fourth quarter shot maker look at this
this is a 25 footer which is someone la
first you are watching the Western
Conference Finals on TNT here's the
steal by Harden fourth turnover for the
Warriors and flowed to his favorite spot
Tucker knocking down another three I
mean look at this that's like five feet
behind the three-point line here look at
this last offensive play look both guys
go out to Hart now watch curry look back
like come on we supposed to switch
really non-existent courage don't go
right into the body of step yeah that
that Looney didn't touch come on
nothing curry can do through the legs
step back noon lock getting it cooking
here in the third quarter release and go
a little bit of room but here's back to
curry dancing this is his tomb this is
his house he told you cool there's the
beautiful layout by courage going where
he's gonna get him as his hands oh you
see that left here until that's when he
gathers his self for his jump shot make
your presence pillow okay
there's now five to 15 look at the bath
Oh we'll get this dime no tennis with
the left hand
[Applause]
well they're going to be able to
look at this beautiful move here by
James splits three warriors defenders
gets back to a strong hand that left
hand again is Raymond look at this
effort you can't tell me he shouldn't be
top three two defensive player B here's
the quick move by curry there's a
Content no call that finishes the Blake
curry coming in looking to help defense
anticipate the pass to the corner klay
Thompson remember him posed for time
weird out of 315 dating of affords the
Warriors with a 12 point lead